is the founder and editor of compact he
says that the problem is deeper no
Corporation should have this much power
over our freedom to speak so thanks so
much for coming on tonight so that that
and that was my summary of your view
tell us what do you conclude from this
thanks for having me Tucker the great
danger in what we've now seen we all
suspected it of course all along but now
we have confirmation that shadow Banning
was happening the great danger in this
isn't that our freedom of speech is
suppressed although that's horrible and
of course these platforms are where
freedom of speech lives or Dives but
that that the process that allows Elite
opinion formation is a sealed off bubble
right that we hear for example that
Vladimir Putin doesn't hear alternative
views about his war strategy in Ukraine
and that's why he makes bad decisions
well the same thing happens through a
Less Direct State directed mechanism in
the United States and across the West it
happens through privatized censorship
through entities like Twitter but
importantly not just Twitter Facebook
Etc if uh our Elites aren't willing to
listen to dissident voices of eminent
doctors like Dr Jay batarchaya as we now
know for sure then they don't they don't
make good decisions right because
they're they're convincing themselves as
sealing themselves in a bubble not
ultimately that different from the kind
of bubble that you know a Gaddafi or a
Putin create in a different way in their
own sort of councils of decision making
so that's the kind of scary part of this
is that our Elite are themselves
structurally turning themselves into
bubble boys
and into what they say they hate I mean
I I honestly wondered I don't know the
answer but could Russian media be more
controlled than American Media is I mean
maybe but maybe not
yeah I mean the the in 2020 obviously I
I was working at the New York Post that
Confluence of corporate big Tech deep
state blue check media all working
together you saw that in a way it was
sort of more terrifying because that you
there's no Center of power you can say
hey it's this one person we can appeal
through this recognized process which is
why Tucker I think we need we need to
still insist on Section 230 reform I
won't get into the details but basically
the reason Twitter and Facebook and
YouTube and all these others get to get
away with this is that because of the
law in the 1990s that was designed to
help them censor things like pornography
it's called the communications decency
act they're using that they're abusing
that now to act like Publishers but
without bearing any of the traditional
Publishers liabilities and so that has
to be changed because if if you and I
libel someone you know in print or in
the media we face this kind of liability
and of course they do not and that's why
they get to censor they get to act like
worldview Publishers but without being
uh bearing any of the traditional
Publisher's liabilities that needs to
change because okay you know I'm I'm
really grateful truly God bless Elon
Musk but it's not just one company it's
these others as well they're all sort of
monopolistic Giants that we have no
pushback mechanism against them this has
to be have a structural public policy
response
sober Martin thank you so much for
joining us tonight
thanks sir